our last speaker of the day uh is
actually my lawyer which before you get
up uh I want to tell you guys a quick
story about Constantine so Constantine
works at Reed Smith uh Reed Smith is one
of the top law firms in the country and
for many of you you probably don't know
this but your lawyer as you start to
build companies is probably one of the
most important people on your team that
you don't treat the same way that you
treat your employees like you go through
a huge interview process and then you're
just like who's the cheapest
lawyer like probably a stupid idea or
way to do it so I thought a great place
for us to start is just when you are
hiring your lawyer you're starting a
company you need a lawyer you need to
get Incorporated you need to put all the
documents together you want to be able
to set kind of the groundwork of the
business how should we grill you to make
sure you're the right guy or the right
firm yeah thanks it's great to be with
you all today and um uh good luck with
all your Ventures uh I've heard some
really interesting um ideas and
opportunities so uh I'm in the right
place I think uh in terms of your
question pom look I think you shouldn't
just go to the first person that you're
introduced to I think that would be
unwise unless of course P makes that
recommendation um but putting that aside
you want to know you want to make sure
that your law firm and your lawyers know
your business you want to they want to
know they have to know your technology
they have to know your business
objectives they have to know how you
like to work and they um should be able
to um be a sounding board to you as you
consider your next moves so um I would
say right up front you want to talk to
your lawyers and make sure they have the
technological uh range to understand the
scope of your business processes and
Technology uh because if they don't
uh you're going to miss a bunch of
things now how can you test them I think
this is one of the most as you and I
have talked over the years like testing
your lawyer to literally be like like
are you the Savage that I need to
because you know a lot of people are
looking at it like oh put together my
documents like how bad could you screw
it up news flash pretty bad um but also
as the business gets larger you're going
to deal with employee issues you're
going to deal with competition issues
you may deal with regulatory issues like
it gets pretty hairy pretty quickly and
so how do you how have you seen maybe
the best companies that you've walked
away from the hire like when they're
hiring you guys and you're like man that
company really kind of did their
diligence and and made sure we were the
right firm well I I I think the the
founders and companies that are um the
best to work through are people who are
really confident in executing the
strategy around what they know and being
curious and inquisitive about the things
they don't know a lot of that tends to
be in areas like law and so being
comfortable to ask questions that you're
like maybe this is a stupid question
it's not um and having a really uh
thoughtful and engaging response from
your Council I think is critically
important so the the best companies that
we work with um have leaders who again
are really um able and thoughtful about
their uh primary business operations and
processes but also can see the the
larger playing field and know that there
are a whole host of legal issues and
legal traps and things they need to put
in place um in order to be able to
execute their strategies and I think the
biggest thing I would say
is at the startup
level it's so critically important to
build the foundation correctly because
everything else layers on top of it as
you go in to raising money to your next
series into hiring people into giving
out profit interest into considering the
shape of your cap table Etc and so I
would be really it's really important to
get that right when you're starting
let's say that I'll was starting a
business tomorrow what are like the two
to three big decisions that I have to
get right from a legal perspective in
order to lay that Foundation to be able
to build a company and not have almost
like legal debt later that I got to deal
with yeah so I think first and foremost
you have to have the right corporate
form that fits your um business
objectives that corporate form needs to
be right for a few reasons one is
importantly maximizing your return um on
your time and investment in the business
so things like QBs and and other um uh
Notions around wealth creation and
preservation are important even if
you're like well I'm not really making
any money right now you well you you you
very well may be and if you haven't set
up right you're probably going to be in
a position where you're I would say
losing money but not really getting as
much um of the juice out of the business
as you could and so on this specifically
qsbs is the ability for people to get
the first $10 million or so taxfree uh
on a sale or liquidation event um but
also things like getting Equity from the
business into ra or an IRA 401K anything
like that and a law firm is able to help
set some of that stuff up so there are a
lot of there are a lot of folks who we
partner with who are smart
um to identify this space as ripe for
people who will be great clients in
wealth management or um um m&a or IPOs
down the road we we do stuff with
Fidelity for instance um who runs this
great cap table uh model that's the guy
who runs the Fidelity cap table clapping
in the
back um and so you can you can Loop in
somebody who is really smart around uh
well wealth management trust in State uh
tax planning right up front for probably
a really reasonable price because they
want to grow with you they want to be
sticky with you so that even though day
one you know they they're charging you a
fixed fee that's you know appropriate if
your company is a success well boy
they're going to get to enjoy some of
that success and properly so I would say
so kind of combining those professional
right up
front um is really important and I think
is available and you may not know how to
do that or how to go about doing it but
a good Law Firm or good lawyer will have
those relationships and will bring those
folks and their voices into play right
up front so that you can really um build
the right foundation for your business
talk about um litigation is something as
companies grow
um usually in my experience startups
don't don't go around looking to sue
people it's usually the opposite people
go around looking to sue startups
sometimes it's incumbents because they
feel like they can bully a smaller
company with less resources sometimes it
is uh people who have left the company
former uh Partners or vendors there's
all kinds of different you know groups
of folks who see uh specifically around
times when they raise money and they're
in the headlines and like oh you just
raised $15 million that sounds like I
should get some of it um how do you
think you guys are laughing that's I've
seen it literally tens of times
um how should Founders think about some
of these as uh in preparation make sure
I'm prepared for when this stuff comes
and then also you get a letter it's a
demand letter it's a cease and assist
Etc what does that look like from a
communication standpoint to your Law
Firm sure the biggest source of disputes
at the founder and and early stages of a
company is between folks who were quote
unquote technically part of the the
initial group who received some sort of
equity allocation or some sort of uh
profits interest that the
founder either quickly figures out six
months into it well this person actually
can function as a CTO now what do I do
I've given him or her 5% of the company
and that's a horrible situation to be in
so we see a lot of um issu around that
or you have folks who've resigned and
somehow think that their um Equity is
worth something even though the
company's in the building stage and
start making demands or or um hire
aggressive lawyers to deal with it so
it's important to have people who' have
been through that process and know how
to actually engage um I would say number
one be extraordinarily thoughtful about
who you allocate Equity to at the
initial stages of your company apart
from not wanting to dilute
yourself uh you also don't want to
create
um stress or drama because that wasn't
the right person to allocate it to and
so obviously there's ways to have people
earn into Equity um
but because we sometimes take over
clients after this initial setup we're
having to kind of go back and try to
redo things that could have been done
properly the right time on the
litigation standpoint you just have to
have somebody who's got a spine and say
sorry
nothing's going to
happen you're not getting a penny
goodbye and and deal with it that way so
there are some law firms um I've got
tons of companies who work with like my
brother's best friend runs a law firm
and it's like three lawyers uh they're
cheap um there's other law firms like
you all where former Federal prosecutors
and just you know a who's who of people
who have been in and around law and very
experienced Etc
um is there a right time and a wrong
time to engage a large Law Firm versus a
small Law Firm or like different type of
work that you should work with one Law
Firm over another or should you have
just one Law Firm or should you have
multiple that's a great question I think
um first I'll start with your prior
speaker talking about some big m&a
that's where you want to bring in real
experts and the outcome of that m& is
such that you're not really worried
about what the legal is you worried
about making sure the deal's done right
and you're getting everything you're
supposed to and not have any tail
liability um so you start there as the
you know High maybe highest point in the
process but when you set up a company
there are firms ours included and others
who look at the uh startup and founder
world as as a tremendous opportunity to
um onboard great potential long-term
clients so there there are models of
pricing that those firms have that I
think are digestible by startups um but
with both parties especially if there's
a good fit um culturally and personally
see this as a you know 5 10 year
relationship ending with hopefully a
very exciting monetization event or
longer um I think because the very first
things you do in forming your
company are really important
it's not necessarily has to be a large
Law Firm but it's got to be a really
competent firm that's done it a lot and
so a boutique firm that has the
experiences just as fine as big law in
that context I wouldn't respectfully
hire your brother's three person law
firm uh for that anyway I'd bring him
into maybe something else um so I think
I I I would
be if I'm if I'm allocating resources at
a startup level I think I'm tipping a
little bit more in the legal pile than
than in other piles because of the
long-term impact of of getting it
right small companies 10 20 employees or
less when they have a board meeting I
try my best not to have to go but if I
got to go it's usually the founder and
the other board members and that's it
any startup that is series a maybe b or
Beyond there's a lawyer in the room yeah
why is the lawyer there and at what
point should the lawyer be showing up to
the board meetings the lawyer in that in
that in that setting is acting as a
secretary they're taking notes and
they're um transcribing those notes and
circulating them should be as a courtesy
to a larger relationship by the way if
you're getting charged for that you
shouldn't be just FYI
um but that's why they're there and
they're probably not there at an earlier
stage because of of the cost or you know
disinterest in having them involved that
early you'll probably have less outside
investors at that point once you start
assigning board board seats to your
strategic investors you got to you know
have it all look and feel like they're
they're comfortable having it so along
these lines um one of the things that I
appreciate about you guys and you know
I've learned over the years from great
Founders is a lot of times there becomes
a decision to make and the founder
almost always kind of knows what
decision they're going to
make and sometimes they just make the
decision which is fine if it ends up
being a bad decision it becomes a lot of
questions and the best Founders I find
they know what decision they want to
make but they go talk to their board
they talk to a couple of investors they
may even talk to their lawyers and get
feed back and then they probably still
make the same decision that they were
going to make anyways but what is the
importance of uh kind of communication
but also a little bit of like cover your
ass and make sure everyone's on the same
page and kind of how a law firm can to
that I think you know the best
relationships I have with my clients are
where I'm acting sort of as a consiliary
to the CEO or founder that that's
typically the role I I'll play in terms
of our team and in that context you can
have really open conversations all
privileged of course um about those
types of decisions and how to execute
them and there's always
A variation of ways you can achieve that
um you can have the
lawyer push it or bring it up I mean
it's if it's not controversial it
doesn't matter obviously but we're
talking about things that might have a
little hair on it or or may not be as
popular as as as you would like it to be
and just to clarify what I'm talking
about I've seen how did you spend the
money who did you hire uh why did you
hire a specific vendor um why did you
want to buy that company why did you
want to uh run a certain campaign I mean
these are decisions that usually almost
always involve money yeah right for sure
yeah I I think look this episode is
brought to you by aradon they are a
brand new startup led by a number of
Silicon Valley Legends who just raised
$81 million to build the future of
Internet infrastructure you're probably
wondering what that means let me explain
there are numerous new disruptive
technologies that are being adopted
simultaneously from blockchain to
artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge technology
in order to ensure that these
Technologies thrive in this new world we
need new infrastructure and that is
where arine comes in they just launched
their first product line called Tera
flux which is a Bitcoin minor powered by
the world's first 4 nanometer silicon
chip technology these air cooled
singlephase and dual-phase emerging
cooling miners have unrivaled speed and
efficiency they've Superior uptime and
they leverage a brand new innovation
called Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
idine.com that's a r a d i ne.com go
check them out at idine.com today I've
been on some board meetings recently
actually where the where the
CEO was asked to reduce budget and
expenses not a uh a more common thing
the past year or so as you know and
didn't really have a plan or a
clue and the board members were really
really pissed and they basically told
him that if he didn't have it done in
the week he was fired right and so
that's pretty heavy so my advice would
be number one know exactly what you want
to do and justify it completely
especially in that context when it deals
with money you're you're the one who
knows your business best and the people
on the board don't they know they don't
but they also don't want to hear
somebody who lacks confidence about
their Vision or their execution so if
you hired somebody for something and it
didn't work out own
it I thought this would be great for
these reasons it didn't turn out that
way now I know and we're going to Pivot
to X Y and Z trying to hide stuff or
kind of pushing the blame onto somebody
else comes off really badly I think um
and unless there's like a legal mess up
in in it you're fine you know that's you
know if the business doesn't work it
doesn't work but I think you need to
have that kind of sense of vision and
confidence when you're talking about
difficult decisions you've made at what
point do you hire a general counsel and
bring someone internal and then what is
their relationship or role in terms of
working with external
counsel
so and and I hate to start answer like
like this but it kind of depends on the
nature of your business there are
certain um companies that really can get
away without an internal General Council
really for a long time right up until
perhaps they're starting to contemplate
an exit of some kind and that's because
their business
is commoditized maybe that's the bad
word but it's a repetitive business it
doesn't really change that much the
documents and the Agreements are fairly
similar and the same the revenu is the
same you know they're building building
by adding
customers and you know if you want to
bring in a GC at some point and take in
the legal work because you might be
saving money maybe maybe you start
thinking about that at some
point um so that's one type of business
but if you have a biotech business
that's highly dependent on patents
making sure they're in place looking at
the landscape around how those P Pats
are prosecuted or trademarks or dealing
with intellectual property issues all
over the
world um or you're constantly engaging
with counterparties whether they be
potential new investors or contract
Partners where you're processing a high
volume of documents I might hire
somebody internally at that point I do
think that once you reach a a certain
scale you want to have a chief legal
officer in place because it's not the
highest and best use of your time to be
dealing with that
stuff um there are ways to kind of do it
with outside law firms they have
programs called sment where they lend
you a lawyer you pay them a fee and that
lawyer works for you exclusively even
though they're an employee of the firm
that's one way that's one way to do it
um and the interaction between a general
counsel and and a a lawyer is that
person is the funnel of all legal
matters that come up they kind of decide
what requires outside Council to do it
and what they can do it themselves
and they should be building a
relationship with the relationship
partner at the firm you're working
with on that point I think this is
important for for the audience to know
is it's really important to have a
really um strong relationship partner at
a law firm that you're working with
because the way law firms work is
depending on the clout you have within
the firm you can achieve certain
outcomes for your clients that maybe
other folks within the firm
can chiefly around better pricing making
sure the teams are you know have the
best lawyers on them delaying payment or
in some instances or um you know
bringing in thirdparty relationships
that they have because of their position
within the firm so that's an important
part of your process too as you consider
outside council is the person who's
leading the relationship somebody who is
um well regarded and um in a good spot
within their La room so this conference
is free for everyone to show up but I'm
going to to save them all money yeah how
do they save money with their Law Firm
well I mean it's a great question I
think there are certain functions and
tasks that lawyers do that don't
require five or six lawyers on them
which you may see sometimes if you're
dealing with law firms you're wondering
well who's that person up in the corner
why is that person over there and am I
paying for all these folks before we
actually get to this uh some people may
not realize when you get on a call with
a lawyer you're getting build for every
person that's on the call so if you have
little experience with lawyers if you
get on a zoom call and there's five
people you're not getting build on an
hourly rate of one of those people
you're getting build all five of the
people and so you're saying maybe you
only need one or two instead of five
well I'm saying this there aren't that
many situations that require more than
one or two lawyers on a law firm
especially if they know what they're
doing especially given the nature of
your businesses on these big deals that
we were talking about yeah there's going
to be a lot of people on the deal but
you want that um so don't be afraid to
ask why is this person on the account
why is that person what is he doing what
is she doing um you'll quickly save
money by asking those questions you know
when you see a first year lawyer on the
deal you know first year lawyers don't
really know much uh they're learn
they're training and you know if they're
on your deal you're paying to trade them
so uh that's not necessarily great use
of your of your uh resources so these
are things that I would look to ask I
think you can have a very direct
conversation with your relationship
partner and say Here's the budget that I
planning for this transaction this
matter this
litigation and just have an open
conversation more often than not you'll
probably reach a place where it works
for both sides but if you're wildly off
you should know that right up front and
whether or not this is the right firm
for you so I think this is a really
important point because uh most young
Founders specifically they get on with
the lawyer and then there's always like
the bill and when the bill comes they're
like holy this is expensive right
what you're basically saying is if you
know that you need something whether it
is I need help with this regulatory
thing I need help uh we're buying a
company whatever talking to the law firm
up front and saying this is what I think
I need can you guys give me some sort of
ballpark as to what it's going to cost
and therefore that prevents immense
shock there still may be some
variability in the bill depending on the
work done yeah
I think it's a two-way thing especially
when we're dealing with with um new
companies or folks who maybe haven't
engaged with the law firm like ours um
that frequently we also we also don't
want to be surprised at the end of the
day it's like well I'm not pay for that
uh so we like to kind of engage and say
okay here's what we're thinking for a
budget what do you thinking uh is your
you know here's why we think you just
like any pricing um interaction with
anyone so you you we want to have that
conversation as much as um you all do
not every firm does though they'd rather
surprise you sometimes and say okay well
you ow this money by the way not a good
idea to tell the lawyers I'm not paying
that they're
lawyers um let's talk maybe a couple of
War Stories like maybe don't scare
everyone but like when you're starting a
company you're ambitious you're excited
you think you're going to get rich all
the benefits of
Entrepreneurship can you tell us a
story that will make people question
whether they should start a company
after understanding some of the
complexities and challenges from the
legal
side uh yeah sure I mean you know it's
it's rarer
than not but you know we've seen
companies that have been started by
people who thought they were really
great friends or were both both going to
contribute um very different but
valuable services to the company and it
turns out one or the other didn't or and
these are multiple horror stories uh M
or or someone stole the code and you
can't find the code and this is my
brother-in-law and now we're going to
sue them and these are not like Mom and
Pop stuff these are really good
companies we thought that fall apart
because of those Reon and end up in
horrible litigation so I kind of kind of
come full circle you really ought to
know who you're going into business with
if you're giving them Equity interest in
what they're doing and and make sure
they don't um end up in a place where
you can't stand them and it's I'm not
saying that gly I mean literally we've
had to be in the middle of conversations
between the founder and the CTO or the
CMO because they won't talk to each
other because I didn't say I was going
to do that and I feel like I should have
more and that only happens by the way
when the company's worth more is when
you realize you you should have kept
more for yourself um so a lot of that
interpersonal stuff it can get really
really ugly and we could probably WR
write a book about it yeah um another
key piece I think to a law firm is uh
some law firms are what I would call
like litigation hungry yeah at the drop
of a hat they want to sue everyone it's
like go score Earth and um in those
scarios obviously they're driving fees
but also there's sometimes ego or
intellectual you know uh um kind of uh
reward from going and doing this stuff
but when you're dealing with corporate
matters having a law firm I think that
like wants to avoid litigation but if
gets pushed yeah can end the litigation
sure for for sure the other War Stories
I would say before I address this is
um arguments or just shock between you
you know Founders and owners of their
company and their um series a or series
B investors who you know if you haven't
really protected yourself in the right
way you end up seeing Founders like well
why am I I feel like I'm working for so
and so well I mean if we had been in
here a little earlier we maybe have been
able to help you on the documentation
but you kind of are and that's a
horrible position to be in and you don't
want to work right um the way you had
Envision and again this comes back to
make sure your documents are right make
sure the people who are negotiating
with your investors um or protecting you
we we stepped into a scenario where the
founder who's tremendously talented um
fashion um person she was like is this
she shows her she is this
right uh and then she was showing me the
board composition this is her company
she just launched it she would have two
seats and the person who gave her some
money on the seat would have three seats
and I'm like nope that's not right
that's your company
so and it sounds obvious but it's not
necessarily obvious because when you're
starting a company someone's going to
write you a big check you're like oh you
should probably get something and your
lawyers really need to be out front on
on that issue uh for sure but then
coming back on on the um litigation
Point that's one of the biggest
quicksands a start a startup or early
stage company can have it's super
expensive it creates tremendous
uncertainty around your company it
obviously um Wards off potential invest
s because they don't want to invest in
company litigation so not being in one
is a great idea but knowing how not to
be in one is is an even better idea and
so if you get sued or someone's
threatened to sue you stay calm relax
and don't be afraid to engage somebody
just to say okay I'm going to call them
and try to work this out as opposed to
they just said this we need to hit back
with that and we may get there and when
we do we'll we we'll hit them hard but
kind of trying to negotiate mediate and
work through issues it's really
important we had a situation where where
a client had a disgruntled
uh executive I would call him president
level who just up and left and
then thought he had a put right on the
equity he had which he didn't and hired
some really nasty Law Firm to say we're
going to see you to collect this money
and you know we were like
well you just own share you don't
actually have any of these rights and
threats and threats and threats and then
just really oh we're going to go to
lawsuit we're go to SEC and so you got
to stick we stuck with it had a bunch of
conversations sent them a notice said
you're a regular shareholder please you
know stand down and ultimately they just
faded away when they realized we were
going to go for their
Bluff you know someone less experienced
might have wrote back a letter and
started off a war which would have I
think really hurt the company in that
instance so it didn't hurt that the
person on our side who was having those
conversations is a former Federal
prosecutor to your point so they know
there's some real teeth behind that if
it doesn't fall apart
um but by and large I think that you
know there you're GNA if you sometimes
you got to fight and you fight but again
that's a real big distraction for your
guys businesses so avoiding that
probably a better idea if possible it's
a classic Sometimes the best way to
fight is not to fight at all yeah makes
sense um before I let you go uh help
folks understand I think um when you're
evaluating the law firm can you try them
out and again I didn't hear what you
said can you try them out and what I
mean by that is um a lot of Founders
they may go through the process we
talked about earlier testing and and
talking to a couple I find that they
just hire the law firm and then it's
like you're a law firm and many of the
successful Founders um hey here's a
project you know work on the that first
and almost there's like a a double
opting into the relationship until
eventually it's okay this is the law
firm that we're going to go with for
either all or majority of the legue of
work like what have you seen on that
front um that companies have done well
you know it's f it excuse me it's a it's
a funny um thing to watch sometimes
where you can see especially last 18
months really smart people pivot the
entirety of their business successfully
and change a lot of what they're doing
and yet
when it comes to their lawyer who they
don't like and just from personal
experience find
it like that you can't do that you know
it'll mess up the business it'll you
know really um screw things up and
that's just not
true um to the extent you're not happy
with your Council you don't have to
marry them forever in fact the ethics
laws that applies to lawyers require
anyone who's been asked to stand down to
be super helpful in transitioning um
work and Deals and even sit with a new
Council to make sure they're fully up to
speed so we have an obligation as a
profession if there's ever a change of
course to do that in a way that doesn't
cost much money to the the client and
make sure the client's business is
seamlessly uh moved around and so just
like you would change out I don't know a
non-functioning internal resource you
can do that um with a lawyer maybe even
easy in easier way now you don't want to
get in the habit of changing your lawyer
every a few hours a few months because
that will make a bad
impression one it'll cause that would
cause disruption internally but it would
also not be a good look to the investor
community and I guess on that point um
the big law firms there's not many of
them and investors know most of the
lawyers
the lawyers eventually meet most of the
companies and so there's obviously
attorney client privilege but I do feel
like a lot of
investors understand uh what it means
when certain law firms work with certain
companies and then also if certain law
firms are not being used and so how does
that play into either the law firm that
the startup chooses or even potentially
investors that you're going a raise from
Etc
so a couple things there
one you know if there's there's
investment firms that you're want to
engage with that'll have a certain
expectation as to the council you're
using um both in terms of quality and
ability and when it's with a firm they
know or is within a bucket of firms that
they deem is an acceptable segment of
the industry
um that's fine usually but I would you
know this a little counterintuitive to
my my practice if you have a really good
lawyer at at a at at a a good
firm I don't know that you necessarily
have to jettison them without you know
having an honest discussion with your
investor if if it's that important to
you um because there are other lawyers
who are very capable who aren't at a big
low firm or at a you know highly
renowned Boutique that are you know fine
so that's a give and take between you
and your investor um on that on that
point in terms
of you know you have to be very careful
you can't obviously we we live by very
um rigid conflict rules so we are not
able to represent an you know investment
firm into Tech and then when we rep
we're representing company they invest
into you know we have to get waivers
from both sides sides and tell them oh
we actually have a relationship over
there and then there are all sorts of we
can still move forward if if everyone
wants us to with very specific rules
around you can't have the same people
working on it you have to kind of um set
up some ethical walls between the
accounts uh and that happens a lot and
it's unnecessarily you don't need neily
work look over your shoulder and say ah
they're telling our secrets to the
investment firm that's that's not
happening where can people find you or
find Reed Smith if they want you on
their side well thank you they can they
can call you I think you can can direct
me uh but I mean read smith.com and my
name's Constantine cus it's it's uh it's
pretty easy Constantine and I have a lot
of fun because yeah every once in a
while I just call him and I say hey what
do you think about this situation and
after he gets done talking to me
and telling me how dumb I am then he
gives me really great advice so I
appreciate you yeah no uh pop likes as
he said I know what I'm going to Pap is
the epitome of I know what I'm going to
do before I talk to anybody and I'm not
actually sure you're listening to uh
anybody as you go through that process
but you know you have to go through it
and then you end up exactly where you
started at but you're mostly right then
wrong well and Constantine gave me a
thumbs up perfect all right Constantine
Kus
[Applause]
everyone